so let's let's talk about a little bit
more of a serious topic that
everyone's being affected by and this is
something i want everyone's attention on
because
odds are there is somebody right now
that's going through
some kind of anxiety based on this story
and it's a cnn story talking about why
sexual activity took a pandemic hit
and what to do about it if you're in
that community this is very important
now why would cnn write an article like
this because it's cnn okay
in the age of covet 19 our sexual stock
has plummeted
none of the old excuses like working
late dinner obligations a rough commute
to get in the way
and with nothing else to do on a friday
night why not sex
our libidos are like the stock market at
a high level they go up or they go down
but when they
when you look closely there are numerous
factors physical and psychological
affecting those fluctuations and the age
of covet 19
we're exercising less eating more
drinking and smoking
and vaping to escape the anxiety all of
which affect our sexual health and
self-esteem
we might not change out of our pajamas
or shower as regularly which affects
attraction we're largely shut off from
the outside world and it's external
stimuli
stimuli and more on top of each other
than ever before
and that's leading to anger resentment
and sense of relational
claustrophobia our research even found
that the effects of force prolong
cohabitation during the lockdown led
partners to turn to masturbation and
porn use
and less to sex with each other what a
what a very
family-friendly article i mean it really
gets me you wanted to well
based on your your tone right there half
our audience has just drove upside there
there
they might go have sex right now that's
exactly what it is
watch we lose like a thousand people
everyone's having sex did you know that
you used the word sex in stock in the
same story there so adam
i turn it over to you your two favorites
save that money yeah
well i think maybe it's like save.com
yeah is that what it is but go ahead
i don't think anyone's worried about
condoms these days they're worried about
covet i don't think anyone's worried i
think so
i think there's a bigger concerns out
there than uh
you know wrapping up um but i don't know
there's something about a pandemic cnn
tells me there's something legit going
on sienna writes it you gotta take it
seriously i do
uh there's something about a pandemic
uh that don't make me horny baby i i
don't know like
to use uh austin powers don't make you
horny baby
uh no covet you don't however to give a
shout out to elon musk again the biggest
troll out there there we go i hope
everybody is ready for a [ __ ] summer
thing's about to get real [ __ ] around
here all right so
cover your eardrums you're familiar with
this [ __ ] summer effect
there's so much pent-up demand whether
you agree with this article or not
i guess people aren't having the sex at
times uh as much as they should
or could have yeah uh and now there's a
lot of pent-up demand
uh going on this summer and uh i've
experienced this for
experiences firsthand down in south
beach people have been uh when you're
floored locked up and you're talking to
a girl
has any girl asked you have you been
vaccinated has any girl asked you any
questions like that when you're talking
to her has
anything about kovitt come up pre you
know not
not like all right i'm about to have sex
with you but have you been vaccinated
have you ever go of it yet i think it's
just
but how you have it as anything but have
you covered yet
i think everyone i think everyone asked
each other that no no no
you're talking random you're talking to
i've been married for too long i've been
for a long time i don't know what it is
to be single i don't know the games i
don't know
definitely um work during the pandemic
you're about to have a baby
in about three weeks you're having a
covet baby yeah so clearly this article
doesn't apply to you so maybe you're uh
maybe this cove thing turns pbd on
kicking more than any
other kid we've had that's kicking this
kid is a kicking baby she's fired up to
come out
well but but going back to it when you
are i'm asking you i'm i'm married he's
married you're single
when you're out there in the market
you're talking to folks you're on yeah i
mean i've see you're you're what you're
on
you're on i'm
not so much for sex i'm just looking for
a guy to take care of me
whatever you're on i hear all these apps
from all you guys here that talk
i'm not on any apps
south beach lifestyle when you're
talking to a girl is it coming up at all
it's what coming up covet is anything
because it's coming up all right is it
is it coming out another question
it's anything coming up where kai you're
out there in the market our girl's
asking about covet
is that coming up i don't call it it's
not i've not had
that hey paul
when a girl actually talks to you
when you have the courage to talk back
what do you say i've had two and a half
women ask me
questions shame on you for saying that's
your real dog i don't i don't think he
helps you
here's what i will say here's what i
will say
this is again in florida so there's
other states like if you're in new york
new jersey or california you're gonna be
like bro i haven't been at a bar or a
club in
a year and a half people are out and
about
people are out and about they're living
their best life they're in clubs they're
in bars they're in restaurants
again this is in florida and people are
mingling again
people ain't scared at this point i
think young people specifically buy this
do you buy this article
okay okay go ahead you know have you
guys watched cnn lately or read their
stories
there is no more group of sexually
suppressed people than people that work
for students
that's what i'm the ones i don't get any
sex so they're writing about it so they
need to have a little bit more sex and
loosen up
but you know what if you google you're
saying liberals aren't banging
i'm talking about he's saying you ought
to go work for cnn it would be a lot of
uh
would that help my sexual activity or
we'll actually give an endorsement for
you can i ask you a question yeah
all right and here we go as long as it's
not working
meaning he's gonna ask me
i'm just gonna how many times a week
i'm just saying has there been more
less or about the same romanticism
in your relationship over the last year
this isn't that personal it's like
everything else it's whatever i say
there's going to be
damn i'm kidding tom yeah tom okay
but in general is it because you've been
unlocked in california is it the same
more less man i don't let pandemics or
anything being experienced
man okay okay but are divorces going up
are they the same where divorce is these
things that's a very good question i
feel like a lot of people are like dude
i've been
but i tell you you know what locked in
with this thing numbers are up
i wouldn't be surprised if numbers
there's a couple guys that went through
this guy named jeff and this kind of
bill i don't know if you guys know these
two guys
yes yes you know i have a couple reasons
why there might be less sex going on
during the pandemic number one
i think it's binging on tv shows i think
it's the content of tv
it's dark people watch the ozarks at
night they watch the undoing
they watch better call saul so much
content out there is so dark it doesn't
get you in the mood
for doing that i'm speaking for other
people and i'm looking for reasons plus
with people on top of each other all day
not literally
figuratively or whatever but you know
that plays a role in it too they're
seeing the same person and i think
who could it be the wardrobe
the way i would see it is what is the
greatest stress reliever in the world
honestly like it's got to be the weed
it's got to be the other way around
it's got to be the other way it should
be logical it's it's got to be more it's
got to be like
again my initial point i don't think
pandemics make people horny
what are you talking about oh okay i
know you're having a baby and uh you
know something about uh
covet is not about stopping doing things
in the bet david house dude let me put
it through this one yeah i tell you i'm
gonna ask you a question
sure what and this goes to everybody
paul you can actually participate in
this as well
sam kai everybody if you want to
participate i'm excited what is
the number one give me your top three
stress reliever in your life what is it
i'm actually being serious with you
folks if you're listening to this please
participate what is your top three
stress relievers
some of the comment sections about to go
off yeah but what is your top three
your mind went to a place but i would
say yoga meditation
okay right all right uh that's your
number one
yeah yeah when i think of relieving
stress i'm not like i gotta go bang
someone like i'm not saying that if if
you're in a relationship
if you're in a relationship and you got
somebody if you're in a relationship
what are the top three stress relievers
i'm being serious with you can i answer
yeah i didn't know there were two others
i'm with him i didn't know that was a
stress reliever what are you
like what are you talking about like
okay are you like there's
play-on player one of the healthiest of
human being could do
is have some healthy sex i'm not
anti-sex man
i'm good you know what we find him
married we gotta finally figure this out
no
i'm all in on [ __ ] summer right now
i'm looking at the comment section i'm
actually asking you guys seriously i'm
gonna give you
seriously okay so that's your first give
me your second and third there are no
others okay so fair
fair okay i'm with you there wait come
on there are no others give me yours
a lot of people there's a lot of people
that's not gonna get there's a lot of
people that smoke weed
watch a notebook what else smoking weed
what else is this a lot of people that
smoke weed there's a lot of people that
do yoga
today lots of people but nobody in this
podcast but lots of people smoke weed
lots of people you know yeah i mean sex
is the top three
okay here we go hey kai top three what's
your top three
uh i mean that hasn't been mentioned
that's it taking a nap
nap time not so good he's exhausted
nap time [ __ ] he's trying to say in the
new headquarters we're building we've
got to get a
bed set up how you doing baby you ready
some people said jim we got daniel
aguirre says jim
sleeping a lot of people said music
reading the bible
andrew junior yeah i do that i'd read
the bible and then i go nap and then i
go
let me go back i go pray for adam you
should actually
read the comment section it's hilarious
so what are they saying so here's the
point if you're under a lot of stress
i mean we got drink soy milk because
lower history
mike man he's like that mic i can take
it to a whole nother level here
in 100 seriously this and it might segue
into our next
topic which is why i guarantee you and i
guarantee you this is all
100 seriousness 99 of the problem in
bill and melinda gates
marriage was sex you think so i'll tell
you right it's that insider in formation
i don't need it i i have greatness i
don't need information i go with my gut
so you think i do you think it was bad
sex
i'm saying lack of sex bad sex not
turned on to each other hold on are you
trying to tell me
that bill can't hit it right with all
that data bill has you don't think he's
an analytics guy oh that guy is doing
some numbers crunching
six minutes and 28 seconds that's when i
do this
you got a bad boy you take the key
batman we got
mail yes you got some milk how about how
about the naked swim
parties back in the day that was a
little creepy for microsoft
yeah let's go to that let's go real
quick uh here i have i do have a
production
i predict this at the beginning of the
pandemic i think there's going to
definitely be
a baby boom a pandemic baby boom people
are like i would have to agree with that
people have been locked up i'm not
saying they're banging non-stop like
rabbits but some stuff went down
you're locked up you're in the house you
can't go out
the last 12 months yep has been probably
the most stressful 12 months a marriage
could have had
because of all these different things
that's going on you're dealing with kids
you're dealing with kids not going to
school in many states you're dealing
with work you're dealing with constant
new regulation
fear death you know the the stuff going
on with the
trump biden election protesting blm i
mean it was
none stressful
if people real if you're married you're
in a relationship
hey one of the healthiest things you can
do is to
go you know practice the god-given
practices
no no actually go so you would think it
would be higher than it would be lower
go procreate go have a zombie bring your
kids crazy or with your partner i think
yes
i think this uh people's relationships
is much like the famous new york song
during kovid
if you can make it here you can make it
anywhere if you can make it together
through a relationship
during coding yeah i mean you can make
it anywhere
wow sounds like that's profound stuff
that was that was sinatra
the next doctor phil right there dr
sauce
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye